the second night of last week's first
Democratic presidential primary debate
ended with sleepy Joe's campaign in
freefall we will examine the attack from
Camilla Harris that knocked the
front-runner down a peg then
conservative journalist Andy no is
brutally beaten by an Tifa in Portland
we will analyze how it happened why it
happened how we got here then more pride
pandering from Democrats all that more
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael and old show
[Music]
I was so devastated that last week's
second night of Democrat primary debate
was Thursday night because I did not
have the opportunity to just relive it
all with you on the show on Friday no
Friday show but we will get to all of it
it was somehow even more ridiculous than
the previous night we'll get to that in
a second but first I have got to thank a
wonderful sponsor you know that I'm on
the internet all the time
I mean I live on the Internet I am
coming to you right now from the
internet so that means you're probably
on the internet too
we all are and that means that our
precious precious data are out there for
big tech companies and hackers to just
suck up this is why I recommend getting
the software that I trust to protect my
online activity expressvpn their apps
are powerful their apps use rather
powerful encryption to secure your data
expressvpn runs in the background of
your computer or phone you won't even
know that it's on then you just use the
Internet exactly as you normally would
you download the app click to connect
and voila there you are you're protected
I never go online without expressvpn and
you shouldn't either because I know what
you think you think oh they're not gonna
come for my data nobody wants my dad
what do I even have on my computer let
me tell you something if you're watching
this show you probably look at some
pretty weird stuff
on the internet you probably have a lot
of data on there you don't want to get
out expressvpn cost less than seven
bucks per month comes with a 30-day
money-back guarantee there is no reason
not to get this I know listen don't be a
cheapskate don't think you don't need it
you need it
expressvpn uses cutting-edge technology
it's called a trusted server to make
sure that there were no logs of what you
do online go ahead do whatever you want
to do on the internet whether that means
looking at weird websites or looking at
the daily wire you know what I mean stop
the hackers today big tech companies
stop big brother from grabbing all your
data
take back your online privacy with
expressvpn protect your online activity
today find out how you can get three
months freed Express VPN comm slash
Michael that is expr ESS VPN comm slash
michael mi CH AE l for three months free
with a one-year package expressvpn comm
slash michael to learn more so I'm
watching this Democrat primary debate
I was playing the drinking game last
Thursday the Democrat debate drinking
game where I pour a lot of booze into my
cup and then whenever they start talking
I drink and it was pretty fun drinking
game I highly recommend it
I had deja vu all over again when that
debate started because the second night
of debate began in exactly the same way
as the first night of debate with Pete
Buddha judge this time instead of bado
or work randomly speaking Spanish say
hello and good evening what I'm not just
to Meir Buddha judge well it just isn't
even over yet oh why do you have to do
that why does this is America we don't
speak Spanish sure now in Buddha judges
defense he was at least asked the
question in Spanish the night before
when bado started randomly butchering
the Spanish language he just did it he
just voluntarily did it in this case the
moderator Jose diaz-balart asked him is
it way no snow chase may or may or Opie
toe or whatever you know and so Buddha
judge responded that way this is very
offensive Jose diaz-balart should not be
asking questions in Spanish if you want
to ask questions in Spanish of
presidential candidates then you should
moderate debates in spanish-speaking
countries anywhere in Latin America
South America I guess not Brazil you
could go to Spain and moderate a debate
but not in America we speak English here
now Buddha judge doesn't totally get off
the hook here if I were in this debate I
guess I was in this debate because
Eric's wall well was there and I am Eric
small well but if I had been standing
there in my own body and I was asked a
question in Spanish by Jose diaz-balart
I would say I would answer in English
and I would say also Jose I just like to
ask that you ask questions in English
here because we're in America and I'm
running to be President of the United
States not president of Mexico or of
Guatemala or of El Salvador now
obviously the Democrats can't do this
because the Democrats basically the only
tool they have left is racial pandering
pandering to allegedly aggrieved victim
groups but the pandering got a whole lot
crazier than just Buddha judge speaking
in Spanish the moderator asked a
question of the entire panel
she said it how many of you in your
health care plans
would provide free health insurance for
illegal aliens guess how many candidates
raised their hand raise your hand if
covered if your government plan would
provide coverage for undocumented
immigrants spoiler alert it's all of
them every single one of them raised
their hand and told one hundred percent
of potential voters that they would take
their money and give it away to
criminals to people who were their first
act in America is violating our laws
I guess maybe not 100 percent of
potential Democrat voters because of
illegal alien voter fraud motor-voter
and digging up dead bodies in Illinois
so maybe not a hundred percent maybe
only 97 percent of voters they were
telling that but that is really awful
and it's so easy to do it's so easy to
say I'll give away everything for free
hey do you want to do you want more free
stuff yeah I'm them I'm the more free
stuff candidate but think about what
that also says you are when you give
away something is valuable as free
health insurance to any illegal alien
who breaks our laws you are creating an
incentive to keep breaking the laws so
not only are they they saying that
they're not going to secure the border
they're not going to build the wall
they're not going to get a sport of
protection in some cases they're saying
we need to decriminalize border crossing
they're also saying we're gonna create a
huge financial incentive for people to
cross that border illegally and don't
forget when you encourage people to
cross that border illegally you are
empowering some of the worst people on
earth drug traffickers who are poisoning
our entire country sex traffickers who
are abusing women and girls according to
Fusion and Amnesty International and the
Huffington Post 60 to 80 percent of
women and girls who cross that border
illegally or raped along the journey
when you create that major incentive for
them to do it you are increasing the
likelihood that that is going to happen
you are empowering the abusers and the
Predators who are preying on these these
vulnerable people this trend of free
stuff for everybody not just citizens
everybody in the whole world this trend
of free stuff continued throughout the
whole debate it was mostly a pretty
boring debate it's what you would expect
until
laris came out and decided that she was
just gonna shank Joe Biden live on stage
and watch him in his political career
bleed out on national television so out
of the blue Camilla Harris opens up a
line on Joe Biden and she says listen
Joe I don't think you're a racist but
and as you know when you say but you
negate everything that she said before
that especially in politics so she opens
up this a line of attack and basically
accuses Joe Biden of racism for working
with segregationist senators thirty or
forty years ago more than that at this
point in the US Senate for having a
working relationship with
segregationists in the Democrat Party so
it's not like these were Republicans
they were Democrats and saying that
because Joe Biden didn't support a
federal policy going into school
districts and mandating busing that he
was some sort of racist and I gotta say
it was a very effective attack in this
campaign we've also heard and I'm gonna
now direct this at Vice President Biden
I do not believe you are a racist and I
agree with you when you commit yourself
to the importance of finding common
ground but I also believe and it's
personal and I was actually very it was
hurtful to hear you talk about the
reputations of two United States
senators who built their reputations and
career on the segregation of race in
this country and it was not only that
but you also worked with them to oppose
busing and you know there was a little
girl in California who was part of the
second class to integrate her public
schools and she was bused to school
every day and that little girl was me
okay pretty powerful stuff pretty brutal
attack on Joe Biden the trouble with it
is that it's mostly not true Berkeley
was never segregated by law she's trying
to pretend she grew up in like the
middle of Alabama she didn't she grew up
in one of the most progressive
Democratic districts in all of America
Berkeley
Berkeley in the 60s and 70s this is a
bed as radical as it gets so they never
had segregation by law there now they
did in fact have a sort of segregation
because there was still redlining it was
still hard for black families to move
into certain neighborhoods you had
basically unspoken of codes that black
people either couldn't move in or would
be very difficult so it is the case that
the elementary school she went to didn't
have a ton of black people for much of
the 1960's the middle schools and the
high schools around her were quite
racially integrated there were a lot of
black students there the elementary
schools a little bit less so however
that ended before Kamala Harris got
there actually it ended a long time
before Kamala Harris got there actually
it started to end before Kamala Harris
ever was born we'll explain exactly what
that looked like and where her answer
was full of lies but first support for
the Michael Nolt show comes from our
friends at rocket mortgage by Quicken
Loans finding the right house isn't easy
you're telling me I've been looking for
a house now for probably six months and
just just the part of figuring out which
house you want to buy is such a mess lit
you know especially living in LA at
least though finding the right mortgage
is easy because rocket mortgage makes it
easy their team of mortgage experts is
obsessed with finding a better way which
means that their number one goal is to
make the home buying process smoother
for you
they have industry-leading on-line
lending technology developed in the
heart of detroit rocket mortgage is
changing the game it's there with
award-winning client service and support
every step of the way
Quicken Loans has helped millions of
Americans achieve their dream of home
ownership and when you're ready to
purchase the home of your dreams they
can help you - I love these guys I think
they're great when I do finally make the
move pull the trigger get a house or a
condo those are there there's no
question who I'm gonna use Quicken Loans
just makes it so easy they are ranked
the highest and customer satisfaction
for primary mortgage origination nine
years in a row and they're the highest
and mortgage servicing five years in a
row when you work with them you get more
than just a loan because rocket mortgage
is more than just
a lender more your mortgage really
matters it's not just any mortgage it's
your mortgage you're gonna have to deal
with this for a long time make sure you
go to the best visit rocket mortgage
comm slash don't scan or wles take the
first step forward the home of your
dreams Equal Housing lender licensed in
all 50 states nmls consumer access debt
or number 30 30
rocket mortgage by Quicken Loans push
button get mortgage so Kamala Harris
this big you know huge obviously
premeditated attack on Joe Biden he's
stand-in there he knows what's coming
he's just taking it but it's full of
holes Berkeley was never segregated by
law and Kamala Harris's school was quite
diverse even before she got there so her
school had black students in it not the
year she got there not the year before
she got there but actually all the way
back in 1963 6 or 7 years before she got
there they had 15 black students at that
time the year before she was born
that was 3% of the student body so
busing had already integrated the middle
in high schools by 1967 at that point
this is two years before common law
Harris got their black students
represented about 10% of her elementary
school after busing by 1968 year before
she got there
black enrollment had jumped up to 37% we
got to remember black Americans are 12%
of the population
so obviously this varies significantly
based on neighborhood and based on
community but 37 percent squad by 1970
which was the end of kamila Harris's
first year they're black enrollment was
up to 41% so the claims that she's
making but she was this pioneer of
racial integration in her elementary
school historically quite dubious but
the attack worked very well see the
Democrats always want to portray
themselves as the civil rights pioneers
which is ironic because for almost all
of American history
they were the opponents of civil rights
even today they're strongly the
opponents of civil rights very literally
they want they attack our First
Amendment rights they attack our Second
Amendment rights they attack all of all
of our basic civil rights in this
country
now a lot of the pundits are giving
Kamala Harris
for winning this exchange and I I think
that's true she did win this exchange
but bad news from a longtime Democrat
politician and someone who knows Kamala
Harris all too well Willie Brown says
none of these people can beat Joe Biden
who's Willie Brown old San Francisco
politician most important for this story
is that Willie Brown basically started
Kamala Harris's political career in his
bed while he was married Kamala Harris
engaged in an extramarital affair with
Willie Brown while he was still married
and then as a result he put her on some
council and launched her political
career so he has a piece in the San
Francisco Chronicle today called bad
news for Democrats
none of these candidates can beat Trump
he writes quote California Senator
Kamala Harris got all the attention for
playing prosecutor in chief but her case
against former Vice President Joe Biden
boiled down in some ways to a ringing
call for forced school busing it won't
be too hard for Trump to knock that one
out of the park in 2020 and that's right
that the busing issue is not popular it
wasn't even popular in the 1970s really
among really any group of people who
never had uniform support and it didn't
really work sort of worked in some
places it did but in many places today's
schools are more segregated than they
were in 1970 because people are choosing
to live with people who look like them
that's not because of any federal policy
it's not because of any D's or
segregation it's because of individual
choices and so if this common law hair
is really think that she's gonna win an
election by rehashing and basically
unpopular policy from the 1970s that's
the best that they've got Brown goes on
in his piece he says Biden did himself
zero favors by telling Harris that he
opposed only busing that was ordered by
the federal government it was a weird
endorsement of states rights and local
jurisdictions right to segregate schools
that's the best argument he could
marshal against busing little kids
across miles across town and that's the
question are we obviously you want to
portray yourself as the most racially
inclusive candidate the most racial
progessive can the least racist
candidate but what is the issue they're
actually talking about forced federal
bussing in school districts so joe biden
obviously he gets hit harris lands the
punch biden tries to respond he starts
to do a pretty good job of responding
harris smacks him down again
do you agree today that you were wrong
to oppose busing in america though do
you agree i did not oppose busing in
america what I opposed is busing ordered
by the Department of Education that's
what I opposed not a failure of states
to in denying public schools in America
I was part of the second class to
integrate Berkeley California Public
Schools almost two decades after brown v
board of education because your City
Council made that decision history four
states failed to preserve the civil
rights of our fg42 year
okay it's a good hit and then she talks
about all these awful policies like the
e ra which would abolish different sex
of bathrooms basically would abolish
different sex sports different sex
education that's called the so-called
Equal Rights Amendment it was shot down
in this also a failed policy of the
1970s but that's all Democrats can do is
just rehash what they view is the glory
days of activism even though those
alleged glory days have a lot of very
bad ideas that go along with them you
can see at the very end there Biden
starts to get his groove back he starts
to hit his progressive stride again he
goes I've always supported the ER a I've
always supported this and that and so
he's doing pretty well and then
incredibly he just collapses are a from
the very beginning
I'm the guy that extended the Voting
Rights Act for 25 years we got to the
place where we got ninety eight out of
the 98 votes in the United States Senate
doing it I've also argued very strongly
that we in fact deal with the notion of
denying people access to the ballot box
I agree that everybody
stay in favish and my time zone myself
oh my gosh what are you thinking my
time's up period quote Joe Biden that's
gonna be the motto of the campaign Biden
2020
and my time's up yeah your time is up
Joe you're sure he had been doing pretty
well but he collapsed because he didn't
know how to end it he didn't know how to
stick the landing it that moment made me
realize why Trump gave him the nickname
sleepy Joe initially I sort of suspected
it was something like this when he gave
him the nickname sleepy Joe I thought
why did he pick sleep either Joe Biden's
kind of creepy I guess it rhymes with
creepy maybe that's good Joe Biden's
disingenuous he's a liar he's a hack why
not lying Joe why not plagiarizing Joe
why not creepy Joe but sleepy is the
attack because he's really old look
Trump is no spring chicken but Trump has
so much energy he didn't he described
himself as youthful and vibrant that's
that that does describe Trump Biden not
so much I mean Biden just ran out of
steam it was like Oh what was I going
what were we talking about anyway I'm
done my times up yeah my time is up and
he actually had a good point to make so
this question of bussing people don't
really like busing even progressive
activists alleged they don't really like
busing even when you do polls of black
voters they don't love busing and of all
people Bernie Sanders on ABC News later
on explained the problems with busing
and that means we have to focus on fair
housing legislation and enforcement but
does that also mean buses your website
actually says that you're coming out
you're repealing of the of the ban on
funding for busing no weave busting is
certainly an option that is necessary in
certain cases but it is not the optimal
does anybody think it's a good idea to
put a kid on a bus travel an hour to
another school into another
neighborhoods and he or she doesn't know
that's not the optimal what is the
optimal is to have great community
schools which are integrated that's what
I think most people want to see that's
what I want to see of course I mean that
makes perfect sense the the issue the
reason that they had busing in the first
place is because of redlining it's
because
certain neighborhoods black people
weren't allowed to move in - fortunately
now a lot of that de facto segregation
is gone
that's over so the question then becomes
why are schools still segregated in many
ways and a lot of that is just by choice
it's by individual choice certain people
choose to live in certain neighborhoods
though they could now now that we're no
longer in the 60s 70s or even 80s though
they could live in other neighborhoods
they just choose not to so now is the
federal government supposed to go in and
say no you're not allowed to live in
neighborhood you want to live in you
have to move to a different neighborhood
because Kamala Harris says so or
something does anybody really want that
that's not optimal and do you really
want to put a kid a little five-year-old
kid on a bus as Bernie says go an hour
to some town that he doesn't know and go
to school with people that he doesn't
really interact with much and does that
ideal no of course not yeah I mean
Bernie to his credit he says guys or are
we really going back to this this is
what we're gonna do but it's because the
Democratic Party has now run to the left
of Bernie Sanders Biden couldn't make
that argument he just fell apart because
he's not smart I've been saying this
time and again since Biden is the leader
of the pack I say at a certain point
we're gonna remember that Joe Biden's a
total doofus he's been a doofus for his
entire political career there was a
reason he ran in 1988 for president and
collapsed and then he ran in 2008 for
president and collapsed and even get
anywhere and he's a joke and he hasn't
really accomplished anything even over
his 750 years in the US Senate and the
reason is he just ain't that sharp he's
not he's not an accomplished guy he's
been in politics a long time that
requires a certain skill but he's not
ready for true primetime and I'm sorry
to say the Camilla Biden exchange was
basically the intellectual highlight of
that entire night the rest just
descended into outright idiocy and for
outright idiocy I turn of course to my
favorite presidential candidate this
year myself
Eric swallow your pistols keep your
rifles keep your shotguns but we can
take the most dangerous weapons from the
most dangerous people so he can't
himself obviously I don't know if you
could hear that he says you can keep
your shotguns you keep your rifles keep
your pistols but we're gonna take the
most dangerous guns away so then I said
okay I've let me just Google and pistols
are the most dangerous guns it's not
hard to find this statistic out which is
the most dangerous gun you go to the FBI
statistics you find out pistols are more
dangerous than any other weapon by a
factor of about 3.6 almost by a factor
of four pistols for the most dangerous
gun but Eric's whoa well doesn't know
that because Eric's whoa well doesn't
know anything he's just he's the Glee
best candidate in the entire race he's
just running on totally empty slogans
you know he ended up endorsing this
Russian collusion conspiracy again no
one talked about Muller directly but a
few candidates alluded to Russia she was
asked what's the first thing that
presidents wall well I don't know how
the moderator even got that phrase out
without bursting into laughter that was
what is the first thing that presidents
wall would do in the realm of foreign
policy and he answered with the glibness
and the self-satisfaction of a 16 year
old running for high school class
president my first act in foreign policy
were breaking up with Russia and making
up with NATO thank you all the smile if
you could just see the smile on his face
there you just got that we're breaking
up with Russia making up with NATO yeah
that was a good one Eric good job man
Eric you're so cool people love you Eric
so that was Eric s wall well
unfortunately I'm sorry to say because
he is me that I'm probably not going to
win the Democratic nomination this year
neither is Eric's wall well but the
greatest candidate of the night was not
common law was not Biden was not Bernie
was not SWA well the greatest candidate
of the night was New Age author and
activist marianne williamson who somehow
managed to get on that debate stage and
she gave a direct threat and message to
President Trump I'm sorry we haven't
talked more tonight about how we're
going to beat Donald Trump I have an
idea about Donald Trump Donald Trump is
not going to be beaten just by insider
sex talk he's not going to be beaten
just by somebody who has plans he's
going to be beaten by somebody who has
an idea what this man has done this man
has reached into the psyche of the
American people and he is harnessed fear
for political purposes so mr. president
if you're listening I want you to hear
me please
you have harnessed fear for political
purposes and only love can cast that out
so I sir I have a feeling you know what
you're doing I'm going to harness love
for political purposes I will meet you
on that field and sir
love will win I love her she may not
have won the debate but she won our
hearts she's this new age hippie type
she says things like reach into the
psyche of the American people for fear
and love what does that mean I don't
know what that means but she's totally
committed to it I I love her I think
she's great
some conservatives have started donating
to her campaign so that she gets better
placement in the debates I think that's
very funny
though I will say my heart is with the
og Marianne Williamson the man who has
been running like this for 20 years and
he's running this time but he didn't get
enough donors or polling or something to
get into the debate this time around
we're hoping he gets into the debate
next time I speak of course of 89 year
old former Alaskan Senator Mike Gravel
left of Vladimir Lenin famously produced
a two-minute long commercial in 2008 of
him just staring into a camera and then
dropping a rock into a pond I don't know
if you if you ever saw this take a look
FN he just stares kind of [ __ ] headed
into the camera then he walks backwards
along the bank of a pond in the woods
somewhere he picks up a big rock and he
he throws the rock into the pond and it
splashes and then the screen says gravel
2008 US I need that man to get on the
2020 democratic debate stage so I'm
really hoping while conservatives are
donating to Marianne I don't want to
take a penny out of Marianne's crystal
filled pockets but we also have to get
Mike Ravel on that stage also because
his campaign is being run by high school
students there there was a video of this
on Vice on HBO where they interviewed
the teenagers who were running his
presidential campaign the funny thing
about this is that it's it's kind of
transcended a particular interest it
just seemed too exciting of an idea to
nods ooh none of the people at this
table want Mike Gravel to be president
including Mike Ravel yeah I don't want
to be President yeah I'm too old yeah
the plan is to get gravel enough donors
to make a 2020 democratic debate stage
and then poke Democrats with extremely
left he takes nothing's happened in my
issues in 10 years and that's what's
what persuaded me to give you my Twitter
account and you're just using me yeah
and I don't mind being used I love him I
can't wait until he gets on that debate
stage so what's the takeaway who won the
second night of this debate the answer
is of the of those the total answer is
Donald Trump he won the night of the
Democrat candidates Elizabeth Warren it
won even though she wasn't there because
Kamala got her shot him but she didn't
prove very much about herself and
actually reminded me of that time where
Chris Christie in 2016
basically just destroyed Marco Rubio's
life in real time on live television and
it totally killed Rubio but it it
actually didn't really help Christie do
you remember this this let's dispel with
this fiction that Barack Obama doesn't
know what he's doing he knows exactly
what he's doing
he is trying to change this country he
wants America to become more like the
of the world we don't want to be like
the rest of the world we want to be the
United States of America and when I'm
elected president this will become once
again the single greatest nation in the
history of the world not the disaster
Barack Obama has imposed upon us
you see everybody I want the people at
home to think about this that's what
Washington DC does the drive-by shot at
the beginning with incorrect and
incomplete information and then the
memorized 25-second speech that is
exactly what he devises David Chris your
state got hit by a massive snowstorm two
weeks ago you didn't even want to go
back they had to shame you into going
back and then you stayed there for 36
hours to the fact here's the bottom line
this notion that Barack Obama doesn't
know what he's doing is just not there
it is he knows exert is what the
memorized 25-second speech that's the
Bears just so awful it was when marco
bott just could just kept going we must
dispel with this notion that we must
dispel that Obama and and Christie just
shanked him I mean like the prosecutor
that he is so it was brutal for Marco it
didn't do anything for Chris Christie
we're not currently living in the
Christie administration he got out
basically right after that so the common
law thing did seriously hit Biden I
think depending on which poll you look
at it knocked him down five to 10 points
in the polls but did it really help her
gave her a little bit of a bump but what
is her path is she really going to be
the candidate moving forward also where
is Bernie Sanders you know he didn't
have a breakout moment in this debate at
all Budaj edge was pretty impressive but
again he didn't really make the case
that he's ready he made the case that
he's actually got a lot of problems with
his leadership back in South Bend I got
to agree with Willie Brown on this I
think that right now none of these
candidates none of them beat Donald
Trump so what the left is going to do
because none of those candidates can
beat Donald Trump is that they are going
to literally and physically beat
conservatives and Tifa the left-wing
terrorist group came out they brutally
beat many people over the weekend at a
preach Patriot prayer rally including
journalists and II know they actually
gave him a brain hemorrhage
and people in the media people in
corporations people in politics are
defending in Tifa making excuses for it
we'll get to that in a second but first
I've got to say goodbye to Facebook and
YouTube go to daily wire.com ten bucks a
month $100 for an annual membership you
get me you get the under Clavin show you
get the Ben Shapiro show you get them at
will show you test questions in the
mailbag coming up on Thursday you get to
ask questions backstage you get another
Kingdom you get the leftist tears tumblr
going to be very very important when we
sue these guys into the ground and the
left-wing terror group and Tifa for
their terrorist activities we'll get to
in a second go to daily wire we'll be
right back
so at this Patriot prayer rally over the
weekend and Tifa came out in their masks
and their black shirts and they brutally
beat people they cracked people's skulls
elderly people and journalists and Ino
was out there he's an editor at quill at
and he was out there just covering
antiva he got brutally beaten and then
sent to the hospital with a brain bleed
here's just one clip
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
get out
so you see him just getting absolutely
clobbered being hit with all sorts of
substances being punched in the head
this is in downtown Portland the
question obviously is where are the
police there reports that the police
were told to stand down not get involved
where are the police they're roving
gangs of violent political terrorists on
the street and the police do nothing
this has been going on important for
months where's the mayor nowhere he's
totally surrendered his town to
terrorists and antiva is a domestic
terrorist group they meet the definition
they use violence against civilians to
achieve political ends that's the most
basic definition of terrorism that there
is and they say that they're
anti-fascist they meet almost every
single definition of fascism they there
it's very hard to get a definition of
fascism everybody uses it it's been
totally overly defined Mussolini did
give a definition of it in 1932 he
described it as violent he described it
as anti-democratic he described it as
authoritarian as desirous of absolute
state power that describes these guys to
a tee they even dress like fascists the
the fascists in Italy are called the
kamichan a day the black shirts that the
antifa uniform is to wear a black shirt
it's to wear all black and they're
wearing that so you've got these auntie
fascists and then you've got people
making excuses for it I mean what
happened to Andy over the weekend was
attempted murder you've seen in the past
few weeks there's a new tactic to
physically assault conservatives which
is to throw milkshakes at them it's
called milk shaking it's really funny
Burger King sent out a tweet in the UK
they said we're selling milkshakes if
you guys want to buy them implying that
they can throw them at politicians
Carlos Mazda that little punk who tried
to get crowder and all conservatives
kicked off of YouTube
he said milkshake them all saying milk
shits throw milkshakes at conservatives
a lot of lot of people saying that over
the weekend the anti-fog eyes in
Portland to put quick-drying cement in
the milkshake cups so as they throw them
they're throwing basically bricks at
people's heads that's how they were
cracking so many skulls that is
attempted murder
and people make excuses for them even
after this happened there was a check
mark a blue chip blue check mark leftist
on Twitter named Sarah Gailey who
tweeted out quote if we can't throw
milkshakes I guess we'll have to go back
to throwing bricks of course no
consequences for her whatsoever when
people on Twitter conservatives are even
some feminists tweet out and say men are
not women they get kicked off of Twitter
that happened to the the author editor
of a feminist journal she said men are
not women she got kicked off of Twitter
for that but then someone tweets out and
says we should throw bricks at
conservatives and no no issue at all a
bunch of journalists self-proclaimed
journalists fake journalists basically
blamed Andino for the attack they said
he was asking for it CJ Worman said that
senior reporter for Huffington Post
Christopher Mathias called Andy a
fascist snowflake for complaining a brat
about his brain bleed and the attack all
of these people you know the the New
York Times ran a piece from Kate Cronin
Foreman who's an assistant professor of
Human Rights which is completely fake
what is what is a professor of human
rights that's not a real discipline she
wrote this piece in the New York Times
and said that we need to Doc's Border
Patrol agents at the border we need to
give out their personal information
their names their addresses where their
families live the implication being that
they'll stop doing their jobs because
they fear for this physical safety of
their family the left has become violent
and authoritarian and what bothers me
the I'm not even that bothered by the
attack I feel bad for Andy he's of
Andy's a very nice guy these attacks
happen attacks do hat it's sad it's
awful I wish the police had done
something I wish that the mayor had done
something but that that always happens
what's so perverse about this is it's
being defended by by journalists by the
media by corporations by politicians
it's even being defended by some people
on the right you know months and months
ago after Charlottesville when President
Trump's comments were completely twisted
and made to mean something that he
explicitly said they don't mean
conservatives pointed out that there
antifa people in Charlottesville as well
and that they're a domestic terrorist
group and they're really awful and MIT
Romney came in tweeted and he said you
know there there's no moral equivalence
he said quote no not the same one side
is racist bigoted not see the other
opposes racism and bigotry morally
different universes he's excusing antiva
Mitt Romney incredibly we nominated this
guy for president in 2012 this guy who
sides with an Tifa and how he look he
obviously got it wrong here he thinks
that those guys aren't bigoted he thinks
those guys don't behave like Nazis he
think I mean those guys are as bad as
anybody in America I mean they are
actual domestic terrorists they are
actually cracking people's skulls open
why does Romney do this stuff why do
other so-called conservatives or
right-wingers do this why would they
side with an Tifa it's because those
types of conservatives the ones who say
I'm a conservative but not that kind of
conservative they actually think that
their side is bigoted they actually
think that their side is sort of the bad
guys and so they don't ever give their
side the benefit of the doubt they say
on the Left they're really the good guys
I mean I want lower taxes so I'll side
with the Conservatives but there are a
lot of wacko birds like John McCain
called them crazies awful people bigots
all of them but every side has their
bigots and Tifa
is possibly the worst organization in
this entire country and you've got the
entire techno media political apparatus
defending them they're still on Twitter
the people who are defending them are
still on Twitter you know when I was
attacked at the University of Missouri
Kansas City by what was luckily a non
toxic series of fluids I don't want to
even get into what those fluids were
luckily it was non-toxic what happened
did the local politician the local
Chancellor of the University did he
apologize no he smeared me as a bigot
what about the local paper did the
journalists come out and say we really
shouldn't be doing this guys we
shouldn't have political violence on
campus no they made fun of me the
did the same thing that that they did to
Andy who obviously had a much much worse
attack so there's a great great tweet
that came out from Andy's lawyer
Harmeet kay Dylan tweets a quote good
night everyone except the antifa
criminals who I plan to sue into
oblivion and then salt so salt into
their yoga studios and avocado toast
stands until nothing grows there not
even the glimmer of a violent criminal
conspiracy aided by the effete impotence
of a cow city government and this is
right we obviously you've got to sue
these guys into the ground you gotta
throw them in jail
for as long as possible and the ones who
attempted murder should hang by a rope
after they are convicted of their crimes
by the civil authority but we've got it
they're not thugs are gonna be thugs
we've got to take this fight to the
politicians to the media and to the big
tech companies who are encouraging it
and we need to also sue them into
oblivion for for their bias on their
platforms for not enforcing their laws
uniformly and for encouraging and
defending threats of violence against
conservatives because what this does
what they do when they have their
paramilitary wing the antifa go out and
crack some conservative skulls is they
say oh that's bad oh we sure shouldn't
have that bad bad nt4 they give them a
little slip slap on the wrist and then a
ntfs still gets to run Portland and what
it says is it sends a message to all of
us maybe you better shut your mouth or
maybe you'll be next
oh hey Michael you just got sprayed with
some weird weird smelly liquid when you
were at the University of Missouri
okay maybe it'll be worse next time
maybe you'll get your skull cracked open
maybe you should think twice before you
go to on a campus tour
maybe conservatives should think twice
before they hold a rally for patriotism
and prayer in Portland really really
scary stuff obviously we'll keep you
updated on how Andy is doing a really
brutal attack for him and and there has
been no answer from corporate America
from the media or from politicians
completely separate story on the other
side of the world President Trump was on
the Korean Peninsula and he was visiting
South Korea and he just sent out a tweet
in the tweet basic
said hey I'm in South Korea if Kim
jong-un wants to meet I'll meet with him
and Kim jong-un accepts the invitation
and president Trump becomes the first US
president in history to cross the DMZ
and go into North Korea it was an
amazing moment here's President Trump
meeting with Kim jong-un talking about
it the relationship has been so much to
so many people and it's just an honor to
be with you and it was an honor that you
asked me to step over that line and I
was proud to step over the line
okay so there are other moments you can
see the moments where he crosses over
the line you can see the moments where
the new White House press secretary is
just pushing these North Korean thugs
out of the way because they wouldn't let
American media and she was fearless she
was great and president Trump's
impromptu meeting is being criticized by
all the usual suspects the parole
closures on the right and the left who
will criticize him for anything and they
say that the big risk is that he's
legitimizing Kim jong-un he should never
meet with the Kim's because that will
legitimize them what does that mean the
Kim's have been in power in North Korea
since 1948 our policy hasn't worked it
obviously hasn't worked you've gone
through three generations of Kim's and
they keep developing their weapons they
stay in power nothing matters at least
president Trump is trying something new
works for me you know the other thing
about this and no one gives him credit
for it is he is the most anti-war
president in my lifetime this guy he
called off an attack on Iran because 150
people would have been killed by it this
guy is a meeting with Kim jong-un it
actually shows a great humility he's
saying I'm not concerned about my own
pride or I'm not concerned about the
image and the optics I will do anything
including more or less humiliating
myself by meeting with this tin-pot
dictator if it means that there's even a
possibility of peace you know he said
this is a historic moment and it will be
more historic if something actually
comes of it I don't think he's
optimistic I don't think he has
unrealistic expectations but he's doing
something
thing that we were doing before got the
kids out of power nothing we were doing
before got North Korea to denuclearize
so Trump tries something new he's so far
given nothing away other than photos I'm
for it you know it's this isn't like
Obama with Iran where Obama gives Iran
the path to a nuclear weapon
it literally sends them pallets of cash
on airplanes it isn't like that what
have we given North Korea we've given
them photo ops if we can get any
progress on the North Korean situation
in exchange for a few photos with Donald
Trump totally worth it absolutely worth
the risk before we go I've got a little
poll that I'm taking this brings us back
to New York
obviously Pride Month is over I think
it's gonna be Pride year next year
though so don't worry that pretty soon
you'll never have to end pride we can
celebrate pride that 365 days a year
but in New York over the weekend at the
gay pride parade Chuck Schumer who voted
for the Defense of Marriage Act Chuck
Schumer who was against gay marriage
until five seconds ago Chuck Schumer
decided to get a bullhorn as always and
pander pander pander here is his big
statement on gay rights
that's it by the way that's the only
argument that is made during Pride Month
is pride pride pride bla bla bla
it's just just mindlessly saying these
words without making any argument but I
wondered there are two senators from New
York Chuck Schumer and Kirsten
Gillibrand Kirsten Gillibrand a couple
of weeks ago she made her grand
statement on the gay rights movement in
a bar wearing a rainbow shirt that said
love is brave here is her great thesis
on gay rights okay so we've got the two
statements here we've got pride pride
pride from Chuck Schumer and then we've
got Kirsten Gillibrand staring off a
camera kind of bouncing around and
saying gay rights so I want you to go to
my Twitter page and I just need you to
vote right now on which Democrat New
York senator has the most ridiculous
pride pandering we need to find out this
is this would be a very highly
scientific poll that's all we've got
today
in the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael Knowles I'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is
mixed by Dylan case hair and makeup is
by Jeshua alvera and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright day Lee Weyer 2019 hey guys
over on the Matt Walsh show today we're
gonna talk about this domestic care
group and Tifa and the violent riot they
staged over the weekend they've done
many of these things many of these
violent riots this maybe was the worst
one yet people were pepper sprayed
bludgeoned with crowbars a conservative
journalist was put in the hospital with
a bleeding brain just awful stuff so
we're gonna talk about all that
including what I think is the most
concerning aspect which isn't even the
behavior of an tyfa as as dangerous and
vile as it is it's the reaction on the
left or lack thereof so we're gonna get
into that today as well over on the Matt
Walsh show